we just met the cow and all loud heat
coming and so is john cena on this
episode of pavli the official peacemaker
companion podcast from hbo max in dc i'm
not going to waste your time let's get
into it why is there a bald eagle in
your car that's equal eagerly is your
pet eagle yeah
is your dog named doggy
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery
[Applause]
all right welcome everyone to episode
seven of podly the official peacemaker
companion podcast brought to you by hbo
max and dc i'm fiona nova and i'm iffy
whiteyway and we're gonna be chatting
about this week's episode i mean we've
got a bunch of things that happened okay
and as always if by episode seven you
don't get it or maybe this is months
down the line and you're just getting on
the peacemaker train if you haven't
watched it yet make sure you pause this
and go watch the show
and then come back and come chat with us
because it's spoilers ahoy ahead we've
got we got like a bunch of just like
mommy issues
daddy issues
parent issues butterfly issues that we
just gotta tackle so let's get into it
the recap of episode seven
[Music]
we are ready we are getting ready to
kill the cow yeah and yeah getting ready
to kill the cow we confronted about the
diary once that's fine we just hop into
the van yeah and that's when we got you
know there's always time to rock they
put on the music they're going they're
rolling out it seems like we're about to
hit this battle and then oops papa's
home oops oops daddy issues yeah oops
all daddy issues yeah yeah
daddy's yeah yeah he's there and him and
his goons are chasing around and we're
seeing like this is some solid action i
mean this is out of all the episodes
this is like the one with the most
action it's like non-stop for
pretty much half the episode yeah yeah
they're just going toe-to-toe you got
you got peacemaker
fighting you know his dad
and you know it looks like vigilante
makes this huge sacrifice yeah they run
into the forest they're getting chased
and then the peacemakers off to the side
that's plot a that's like part oh yeah
we've got a b plot here which is judo
master getting mocked and getting
bullied destroys those fellas i don't
know why they even thought of mess with
him gets his hot cheetos
and drives to find harcourt and um and
leota yeah yeah yeah they're on the hunt
and speaking of carjackings
yeah uh
vigilante just hops in the car and
they're like you left your keys in the
car
he's fast
you left your keys in the car what i was
rushing
ignore it let's go
what was the answer he was like
essentially he's like i
about doing it so he's he's gone they
think nothing of it and that's where
we're learning now that they're able to
track peacemaker with his helmet
which i imagine if you work that hard on
something like a helmet of course you're
going to put gps in it tracker
if it has you know the sonic boom
function yeah x-ray function you best
believe it's going to be find my helmet
yeah find my helmet that comes to the
best thing the raccoon yes yes
we see that an unfortunate peacemaker uh
didn't get it easy it wasn't an easy
transition his face is scratched up he
probably has rape a man's invincible you
know what else you know who isn't
invincible vigilante he's invincible to
a nap yeah the guy just took a nap i
don't know what really happened we
talked about a and we talked about the
bb and judo master then we got to talk
about the c which is you know uh the
newly taken over sophie hunting down uh
for harcourt and leota so let's even
move back a little bit uh harcourt
discovers that leota is amanda waller's
uh daughter and byrne was like yeah i
know i did a background check i'm not
dumb yeah and but you can also see a
time where um adebayo is a little bit um
vulnerable in this day because she's
like i just can't do this i can't i
literally i don't want to and i can't do
this i need to go you also have to
remember like this is kind of the weight
of everything that adebayo has been
dealing with since the first episode
like you know when she thought it would
be simple second episode it's going to
be harder she has she's afraid to kill a
man you know by this point she's
actually taken life so this is just the
weight of the whole season finally
coming yeah to weigh her down and we
have this like tough moment and uh and
it gets even tougher when we go back to
the a thing we were talking about which
is peacemaker getting jumped but it's
also the moment where there's a fight
and
peacemaker kills his dad yeah like shoot
some rain ran the head
yeah that was
a very surprising moment it was
because it really but i like the way it
happens there's something satisfying of
a shitty person
mid you know speech getting just shut up
and you know him being like you can't
kill me you'll never yeah but it's also
like the unexpected right because in a
real situation that's where you get them
right like i don't care how bad your
parents are it's gonna be hard to put a
bullet of course you know yeah yeah yeah
so he's dealing with that yeah
you know he's shaking because eagerly
took a bad hit from his name he did he
wasn't happy he wasn't happy and he had
to protect giggly at all costs but on
the other end mirn also gets killed yeah
they catch merman holds it down like a g
and it's like i'ma stay there yeah yeah
yeah they
they dispatch murn
and we think mirn is good because he
starts to fly away but they're like yeah
no we know what you are snatch him up
out the sky and crushed yeah our boy so
not only is mirn the human mirn dead
also the butterfly so he's definitely
not coming back yeah yeah yeah poor guy
and i feel i mean we'll remember because
he even had his last thing where he
touches touches the fingers your finger
like that and i felt so and i i think
that was also the moment where harcourt
felt like damn that was the only other
person that could understand how i'm
feeling right now and the person that
she looked up to and he's dead now and
there wasn't like a moment of grieving
that like she couldn't even like express
or just going down it's going she had to
make sure she get the cow
and then and then immediately after she
has to go into a fight with judo master
because he came in oh my gosh yeah he
was
mad and
and this is this is where you know we
get to see her take it to the match you
know she takes down judo master well
they were it was a pretty good match oh
yeah actually they were pretty much neck
to neck and then adebayo came in with
that taser yeah i came in that taser and
tasted him yeah took him down yeah
dispatch dispatched but yeah i think
like another scene that i
love is when they're now bringing eagley
to the vet but now the vet nurses are
being held hostage by vigilance
vigilante is trying to murk these
nations
her wood's kindly stitched up eagerly
and vigilante's being a total freak dude
they saw us peacemaker and i were wanted
what other choice do we have besides
killing this veterinarian this nurse and
this male nurse you could just say two
nurses man
if i just say nurse i think people will
imagine it as a woman he's standing
right there we don't have to imagine
anything
must be weird waking up every day and
being a male nurse
do we really have to kill these people
no
with valid reasoning it's like well
they've seen our faces they know what
we're doing we've got to take them out
and the p everyone's kind of figuring
out like
but but yeah this is this is the turn we
see in harcourt because remember this is
an episode two discussion where she
murked that secret service agent without
a second thought because they know and
this time
she decides to let them live and to tie
them up also we get to see eagley hug
yet again action hugs and yes adebayo
sees the hug
and then and and
calls her partner yeah she essentially
is like i just saw an eagle hug a human
and i think that's a sign so i'm gonna
stay
because this is blowing my mind they set
harcourt as the leader there's a new
leader because that is the new that was
the second in command essentially
and uh we get a really
a scary glimpse of the cow yeah so
yeah that was the
chunky
yeah and that's the cliffhanger that's
left and all all there is is the last
episode yeah so yeah that's essentially
the recap there's a lot that went down
this episode and i think there's a lot
of things that we weren't able to touch
on but those were just like i think the
need to know the need to know moments
but i i i just gotta i do i'm just so
excited for this interview we've got a
very amazing and important guest here
john cena himself and we have so many
questions to ask this guy
so many so stick around you're not going
to want to miss this
[Music]
hello everyone i am here
joined by john cena the peacemaker i am
so excited i mean i speak for iffy and i
when we say
john you've been so good at um just
being the best version of peacemaker we
could ever imagine uh you are emotional
but you're also like really funny and um
downer i i don't know i just i think
peacemaker as a character is really
amazing so i would love to know your
take and how you felt about how um
you're portrayed a peacemaker in the
series well there's been a long legacy
of performers who have done the
peacemaker outfit uh there was um
there's been a
i'm the only one who's put on the piece
yeah
the fact that you can't see anyone else
playing peacemaker is at least safe and
sound
seeing a peacemaker came from pretty
much oblivion he's not a well-known
character uh we saw a little bit of
debut of
a man who will keep peace at any cost in
the suicide squad and um i guess james
gunn thought that there was
a story to be told around that ethos and
around the character and um man i
thought the suicide squad would be the
last time we saw a peacemaker but here
he is back in in peacemaker the series
for hbo max so thank you very much for
the kind words i know i'm uh being
sarcastic early on but uh i just kind of
just trying to use attention yeah no
it's a fun fun fun ride and you know
speaking of fun rides the show
is perfectly self-aware so
how is it working in this kind of comedy
environment i i like it because the show
isn't a comedy uh but it is it's not a
superhero series but it is
um
it's it's literally a collection of
personalities
brought together to achieve a goal
everybody's got their different
perception about that goal
and you follow them around uh during
their life not just
the times of tension where the mission
depends on it i think that's
a small difference between something
like the suicide squad and peacemaker um
you see those between moments and
because it's an episodic you get to lean
into a lot of the nuances you get to
know
peacemaker you also get to know chris
christopher smith and i can say the same
about the dynamic of
every other character and i think that's
again i think that's james gunn enjoying
himself the fact that he has eight
episodes he can lean into all that help
yeah totally and so
okay peacemaker just in the comedy side
says that there's never a bad time to
rock right and we love your we'd love to
rank these moments
uh where from worst to best
when is the best time to rock okay we've
got a funeral
making a sandwich
singing the national anthem having sex
and riding a crowded subway
i i think um
candor at memorial services
probably would rank in a category by
itself i think you got to know the room
on that one i think every every other
experience you just mentioned is a
perfect time to rock
perfect
i don't know about riding the crowded
subway i'm from manhattan don't continue
there's a wrong time to rock don't do
that
[Laughter]
you know
i've been licking my lips while watching
the show uh mostly because of the amber
goo that the butterflies eat what do you
think it tastes like oh um i know
firsthand it it is
i know at least
from from a
props perspective that it is uh sugary
based
i it tastes better than slime like a
nickelodeon farm i know that
uh
yeah i uh i got a little up close and
personal with the goo
and that right there is a sound bite
that should vault this podcast into
another dimension thank you for that
thank you yeah yeah yeah oh yeah thank
you sweet and savory it's everything i
desired at that moment yeah your
curiosity genuinely has no bounds
interesting i love that i would love to
know that about you yeah you should you
should see what's going on below my
waist right there and i was like perfect
framing for us to not know
it's a tease
all right and so
since we're talking about episode seven
it seems like uh peacemaker actually
catches a raccoon to use as a decoy is
that something you think you could do
that's uh i would not be curious about
that in real life
yeah that's that's a bad that's a bad
maneuver those things are so cute but
they are so wild oh yeah and there's
there's a reason they they still exist
that's their ability to defend
themselves and just they'll they'll want
to take you on oh yeah here and through
the trash can you're in your pjs you've
got to see what it is it's a raccoon and
you better just
fold go back to sleep don't try do not
do not try yeah just take the l why
would you even try to try to win that
battle yeah i just like the fact that
peacemaker is constantly getting
throttled by like in the first episode a
very unlikely opponent comes out of
nowhere and hands peacemaker his ass oh
yeah okay so that's how we're introduced
to this guy and then a raccoon hands
peacemaker his ass like i like the fact
that he's not
that good in those respects well you
know let's let's take the flip on that
and if you could get a hug from an
animal which animal would you choose
[Music]
being hugged by a bald eagle when you
see it in cgi
is pretty dope i think uh
that in my real world that was a memory
foam bowling pin shaped gray object
so
when i see that i have a different
experience but like seeing
seeing me getting hugged by an eagle i
think i an eagle ranks right a bald
eagle ranks right
on top of that list yeah yeah you know
to
wrap up the interviews we always take a
question from the community so uh this
is our eagle email yeah all right
[Music]
stop waiting for the graphic i'm sure
something kick-ass happened no we'll
make something extremely low but it'll
be like it'll be a yellow post-it thing
and just be a flip book of like
oh hello bud we have no graphic support
for eagle male eagle email yeah just
staying email that's it
you might you might have to sing the
jingle i think for the for the audio you
want to do that yeah we'll need that
eagle email
that's it we got it there it is there it
is
all right so this person from the
community asked if streets are talking
what are they saying what's what's the
word yeah what do people want i have i
have no answers and i will just spew
misinformation this person asked mr cena
have you read any comics with peacemaker
be it before or after the release of the
suicide squad and or during the
production of peacemaker or did you
approach the role as mr gunn wrote it
and directed you to play it so that's a
great question
i'm going to give you the answer first
to which you will have an emotional
response then i'm going to give you my
why
the answer is no i did not read any
comments before or during production
i'll allow you to emote
here is my why because the very first
thing i did when i got the job i shook
james gunn's hand and said do you want
me to get every comic or periodical or
any anything about peacemaker and study
up he's like no
the reason i've chosen peacemaker is
because many different uh artists have
given different interpretations of
peacemakers so it's kind of a
this is a great character because it's
up to us to craft it
and i think james's depiction of
peacemaker
like everything he does it stays true to
the to the art the crazy silver toilet
helmet the enormous
desert eagle
so like it's it's true it's true to form
um but he wanted the ability to be able
to tell the story and a lot a lot of it
was kind of like decisions made in the
heat of the moment you know his uh you
know he's a douchey bro captain america
that i never would have got that from
the comics yeah so i think he didn't
want me to read those comics because he
didn't want me to develop biases to come
on set and be like no the comp the
comics say this
so i know what you're telling me but
peacemaker is more like this because of
what i read
and it actually worked out great because
you know the the peacemakers material is
it's archival it's old it's not of today
so to to take a character and
retrofit all the stuff and make it
appropriate for what james water cops in
the series
he actually gave me the advice not to
read the comments and i'm glad he did
because we have this family behind me
that i'm very proud of oh yeah i
completely agree i your peacemaker
is my favorite peacemaker so
you know what i even though it's a
listed one
i will take that
you know i've always i've spent most of
my life being called number two so i'm
gonna take the time right now as the
only person who's ever done the
peacemaker outfit to be the number one
peacemaker you are the number one
peacemaker now because you pulled out
the desert eagle i just need to know
what other props did you bring to the
show
before we wrap it up so like i said i
can't really show you below my waist uh
it's not what you think it's actually a
bunch of tvs airing old 70s world's
strongest band reruns
what a twist
i have the gloves and i have the full
piecemaker outfit the one thing i don't
have uh
is the helmet i lost it in a sucker's
bet to jimmy fallon last night in the
tonight show
so i don't have the helmet um i don't
own it anymore and to be quite honest i
didn't know it in the first place so uh
okay
as they say yeah but yeah i have
this is a cool this is not a real weapon
as you can see yeah
well i believe you can yeah i was like i
can believe you could bend the real gun
so
i also think things like this because
you look at the comic book art
peacemaker does carry a giant silver
sidearm
but as we learn more about peacemaker
this is obviously a compensation piece
as well so i think there's a bunch of
stuff
that peacemaker does and how he defines
his character the bright uniform they
touch on that in the series
certainly his uh man even the uh
the devin peace engravement weaponry i
think
everything has meaning and all that
stuff is true to art form so it's uh
it's cool to be able to see this stuff
and man that our profs guys did an
awesome job with this stuff and
lending it to me for the afternoon so
very grateful
okay john might have a little background
difficulty those are those budget cuts
we're talking about right fiona yeah
right
you'll see it in the graphics too
actually yeah yeah so it happens it's
hollywood baby
i
it's hollywood baby amazing again uh
john cena you've been amazing as
peacemaker and that and the show has
been so fun to watch
and uh really it's been such a ride so
great job
i just want to say great job yeah well
no thanks i'm glad everybody enjoys it
we had a bunch of fun making it and i
hope we can make eight more seasons so
that really
i'm a bit into the character yeah yeah
me too me too let's keep it going
peacemakers eight seasons in a movie i
got the first wind of funny john when i
saw you in train wreck and i lost my
mind i was like oh
oh john's like funny
oh
thank you man i always say that uh
you had you had great comedians and
certainly a great comedic mind and judd
you know uh at the at the ship's helm
and they created an environment
to bring in this guy who is not familiar
with comedy and say listen okay
you can tell 65 bad jokes we're gonna
run
all i need is one good one
so like they would give you the ability
to fail and a lot of times
when you're out there doing a stand-up
set you don't have that ability when
you're out there performing live
you don't have that ability but when you
create an environment for somebody to be
like i know you're new to this you have
those really funny people around you
and you can fail
go for it yeah and i hats off to them
for being able to
have a little faith in me to waste some
tape and hopefully get some good jokes
yeah yeah thank you so much john it was
so great talking to you
thank you for you you guys for having me
thanks for for being a vehicle to keep
the peace yeah and uh man i hope people
enjoy the series oh they will oh yeah
that i'm never been more confident of
anything you have made a 100 percent
guarantee of satisfaction how am i going
to deliver that how are we going to live
up to the hype
john you did you did we 100 guarantee
that peacemaker will happen
you will feel a certain way about it
okay all right and we would like you to
share those thoughts engage in social
media on how you feel good or different
see you later
oh man
and i already miss him i want him back
here oh man what a great guy so excited
it was so great to finally just chat
like i love chatting with all these
casts cast members and people like
behind the scenes just getting a glimpse
of how peacemakers made and just get
getting even more about their characters
i'm loving it yeah get an info on the
peacemaker sausage oh the peacemaker
sauces well let's go ahead and uh
get this peace prize going um
[Music]
okay yeah we got the peace prize one of
iffy's favorite segments
of the show and um
i think this is a no-brainer yeah we
have an amazing warm
and wholesome eagley hug
and guess what award we're going to give
it the eagles
award we have to because that was the
hug and it's an eagley hug award of
course we have to give it that award
because that was one of the most
touching and sad and also most wholesome
scene personally that i felt and also it
made it even better that adebayo saw it
too because she didn't believe it but
she sees it and that is a sign that
she's going to continue on i know
especially to like you get to see
just this extremely vulnerable version
of peacemaker who's praying and
hoping that eagerly survives this this
and he does and he does spoiler alert he
does
you don't need to be sad don't cry
he does he makes it back he rises from
the grave essentially to give peacemaker
a hug and oh
oh man we how much we love eagley yeah
we love eagley but yeah that scene was
great um and i think it definitely
deserved this award so
eagley hug goes to the eagley hug there
it is there it is
well on that note uh i think uh we gotta
close out we've we've had so much fun
hanging with you talking about
peacemaker thanks for watching i mean
this was the pent ultimate episode the
next episode will be the finale of both
the show
and the podcast yeah and then we lose
our jobs
[Laughter]
if you haven't already subscribed so you
won't miss an episode when you subscribe
and if you want some awesome and sweet
merchandise check out
shop.dcomics.com to get some amazing
peacemaker merch you're not going to
want to miss it and even though the
show's finale is next week it doesn't
mean you have to stop ingesting comic
book media make sure you get the dc
universe infinite account so you can get
access to so much comic books so much
more you'll love it trust me i have it
and i love it but also please don't
forget to follow us on
instagram
facebook twitter and you know start the
conversation with us let us know your
favorite scenes and of course make sure
you're streaming new episodes of
peacemaker and podly the official
peacemaker companion podcast from hbo
max in dc
on hbo max okay until next time
keep the peace
keep it keep it
you